what are some of the tax things that
you've learned man because I think some
people don't understand like if because
if you sell a hat like let's say you buy
and you sell a flip right yep
um wouldn't it be in your best interest
to take all that money and put it into
another property as soon as possible or
what like kind of give me some of those
tax loopholes that are legal that are
legit that you know well you know
everything when it comes to flip
properties everything is a write-off
right from the interest that you paid
you know your hard money lender the
points everything's a write-off and
everything that you buy your you know uh
the taxes you paid on the property the
insurance everything is right off right
so you don't really pay that much taxes
when it comes to real estate because you
have so many riders and so many expenses
they you could take off the you have to
pay capital gains taxes on the profit
yeah okay if you hold it for more than a
year right uh you pay less right uh but
yeah you have to pay Capital Gains but
again it's all numbers you know what
cost to do in business yeah is the cost
of doing business but there's so many
expenses right that you can write off
that uh you know you could always win
you could always win rental properties
that's really where you want to be
because with rental properties you have
depreciation right a rental property for
some reason right is considered a
depreciating asset so every year you get
to write off a certain number right so
let's say for example right let's use
big numbers
um
I made three million dollars in rental
income last year right but I have two
million dollars in depreciation right so
I could depreciate the asset for 25
years right
so three million dollars I made but I
have the appreciation of too many right
so now I only pay taxes on one million
um but I made three million
but it's in the cold because of
depreciation that I can write off two
million so now I made three million but
you're only paying taxes on a million
yep I party with the with three million
you do yeah yeah but now I only pay
taxes on the million yeah that's why
that they consider a rental property a
depreciating asset yeah I mean it's
great for for you right yeah is that
just because it's something that you're
not personally living in and people like
live yeah and it's a wear and tears
stuff like that wow yeah so so you know
that's one of like the best loopholes
there are when you're a landlord right
yeah and the cool thing is about it that
even when you write off right that's two
million right as a loss
when you go to the bank to apply for a
new loan since they already know what it
is they actually add back that 2 million
so you still qualify for more so ah so
the bank knows you'll still make three
the bank knows what's up yep wow that is
wild man